When we used GPT 5.5, as we increased
the number of tools, we actually saw an
upward trend on our evaluation set. And
to us, that was a clear sign that this
model is better able to synthesize
information.
My name is Chaitana. I am the head of
engineer for our clinical decision
support at a bridge. What we're trying
to build is effectively how can we use
the world's medical information, how can
we use all the patient context, the live
conversation between a patient and
doctor [music] to help clinicians in
making decisions. What was amazing about
leveraging GPD 5.5 [music] is that we
saw higher better clinical reasoning and
tool use. Basically [music] the
information density is much better now
and for clinicians because medicine is
quite complicated. What we want to do is
we want to bring [music] the most
information density right at the point
of care and then they can make the
ultimate decision. The thing that
excites me the most about this model is
that as [music] we keep adding tools and
context, we believe the model will
actually be able to keep up with that
complexity and as such it's able to
deliver far more value to our users at
the rigor that we want and that [music]
we need for such a product. We saw a
clear clear jump in the results and it's
been really exciting partnering with
open eye on this.
[music]